Yeah.
So I'll thank you for that
lovely in production and uh, uh,
and thank you for um, sharing lunch,
sharing your lunch hour with me.
Um,
so I think what I'm going to do is kind
of jump into the talk and if there are
procedural questions you have
or questions about methods,
I'm happy to take those questions now.
Otherwise we'll just wait till the end.
So lots of tech companies are trying
to figure out how to detect emotion by
reading facial expressions.
It's a really exciting time because
the technology is a developing really
quickly advancing really fast.
Um,
and in fact the pace is
even seems to me anyways,
kind of speeding up and there
was a growing economy of um,
emotion reading gadgets
and apps and algorithms.
But the question I want
to start today with is,
can we really expect a machine
to read emotion in a face?
There are plenty of companies who
are claiming to have already done it
and their claims are
based on some fundamental
assumptions that we're going to
systematically examined today.
And I'll just warn you,
I'm going to maybe suggest some things
that some people might find a little
provocative and might challenge
your deeply held beliefs.
Um,
because the message I'm going to
suggest today is that machines,
it's not the case that machines
can't perceive emotion,
but that company's currently seem to be
going about this question in the wrong
way because they fundamentally
misunderstand the nature of emotion.
And as a consequence,
they're missing what, uh,
I would think of as a game
changing opportunity to
really transform the science
and its application to everyday problems.
So emotion reading technology usually
starts with the assumption that people are
supposed to smile when they're
happy, frown when they're sad, scowl,
when they're angry and so on.
And then everyone around the world should
be able to recognize smiles and frowns
and scowls as, uh, expressions of emotion.
And it's this assumption that leads
companies to claim that detecting a smile
with computer vision
algorithms is equivalent to
detecting an emotion like joy.
But I want you to consider
this evidence. This, um,
here on the x axis are the presumed,
uh,
expressions for, um, the
various emotions. For anger,
disgust, fear, happiness,
sadness, and surprise.
And now we're going to look at
some evidence from Meta analyses,
statistical summaries of experiments to
answer the question of how often people
actually make these
faces, um, during emotion.
And the answer is not so much
the y axis represents the proportion of
times that people actually make these
facial expressions during
actual emotional events.
So in real life, for example, um,
people only make a wide eyed gasping
face during an episode of fear 9% of the
time across 16 different
studies. And in fact, that face,
if you were in pop when a Guinea in the
Troy brand islands would be considered
an anger face. It's a threat face. It's
a face that you make to threaten someone.
So in real life,
people are moving their faces in a variety
of ways to express a given emotion.
They might scowl and anger, um, about, uh,
30% of the time. Um, but
they might cry in anger.
They might have a stone face stare and
anger. They might even smile in anger.
And conversely, people often make these
faces when they're not emotion at all.
For example,
people often scowl a,
a full on facial scowl when they're just
concentrating really hard. Nevertheless,
there are hundreds of studies where test
subjects are shown posed expressions
like these.
So post faces and then they're asked to
identify the emotion being portrayed.
And again,
the proportions are on the y axis.
And so you can see there's
quite a difference, right?
Even though people only make a wide eyed
gasping pay face about 9% of the time,
68% of the time.
Um,
test subjects identify that as a fear
expression and so on and so forth.
So which data are the companies using to,
um, to, uh, as the basis
of their development?
They're using the blue bars.
So when software detects
someone as scowling,
they infer that the person is
angry. And in fact, you'll hear, um,
companies refer to a scowl
as an anger expression,
as if there's a one to one correspondence
and frowning for sadness and so on.
And so the question is,
well,
if people sometimes make these
faces to express emotion,
the d the presumed emotion,
but often not.
Why our test subjects as perceivers
identifying emotions in these faces.
So, um, so frequently. So why are the blue
bar so much higher than the white bars?
Um,
and now I'm going to show you the answer.
Here's the kind of experiment that is
almost always used in the sorts of studies
that generate the data for those blue
bars. Test subjects are shown opposed
face like this.
And then there I'm shown a small set of
words and then they're asked to pick the
word that matches the face.
So which word matches this face?
Good job.
When test subjects choose the
expected word from the list,
it's called accuracy.
Even though this person is not angry,
in fact,
she's just posing a face.
And in most of the faces that
are used in these experiments,
subjects are just posing faces right
there. So it's not really accuracy,
it's more like how much did you agree
with the experimenters expectations,
but it's called accuracy. So that's
what we're going to call it today too.
So hundreds of studies show pretty
high accuracy using this method.
This is on average.
So this is a Meta analytic average
across hundreds of studies and, um,
emotion perception,
you know,
feels as easy as reading words
on a page because in fact,
that's actually what's happening
in these experiments. Um,
when you remove the words and you merely
ask test subjects to freely label the
faces,
accuracy drops precipitously.
And for some emotions like contempt
and shame and embarrassment,
uh, the rates actually
dropped to chance levels,
which is about 17% in
most of these studies.
And here's what happens when we add a
little bit of diversity into the picture.
So things get a little more interesting.
So we tested a group of hunter
gatherers in Tanzania called the Hadza.
The Hud's, uh, um,
have been hunting and
gathering continuously as a
culture since the pleistocene.
They don't live in, um, you know,
the same exact same circumstances as
ancient humans, but they are living,
they are, you know, hunting and
gathering, uh, on the African Savanna.
So they are living a lifestyle that
is similar to the conditions that some
psychologists,
evolutionary psychologists believe,
gave rise to these universal expressions.
So there a great population to,
um, to test. And there actually
aren't that many of them left.
It's actually really hard
to get access to these, um,
to this group of individuals.
You have to have special research permits
and so on. Um, so we were able to,
with the help of an anthropologist who
we collaborated with get access to the
Hadza and who were very generous
with their time, um, and um,
you know,
labeled some faces for us.
So we showed them a set of faces and we
ask them to do exactly what we ask other
test subjects to do. Uh, and um,
accuracy actually dropped even further.
And this number is actually a little
high because what the huddle we're very
good at doing was distinguishing
a smile from all the other faces,
which were depicting negative emotions.
So when you just look at the, um,
accuracy for, for labeling scalpels
and pouts and things like that,
just the negative depictions
of negative emotions,
the rate dropped even further,
pretty much to chance levels.
And so this is what happens when you
remove the secret ingredient from these
experiments.
Um,
the evidence for universal
emotional expressions vanishes. No,
I'm not saying that that means that faces
carry no information or that we can't
look at a face and, and uh, make a
reasonable guests about how someone feels.
But what I am telling you is that human
brains are doing more than just looking
at a face when they make such judgments.
That is right now when you're looking
at me or when I'm looking at you,
some of you were smiling and nodding.
Thank you very much. Others are, you know,
maybe looking a little more skeptical
or at least that's the guests that my
brain is making.
My brain isn't just using your face.
There's a whole context around us.
Um,
but in these experiments
were just looking,
the experimenters were looking only
for the signal value in the face alone,
stripped away of all context
except the context that they,
unbeknownst to them actually had provided
to the subjects, which are the words.
So to just to confirm that,
um,
that, you know, the experimental
context was actually,
uh,
generating evidence making,
making that it could make
any emotion look universal.
We decided to test this by going back
to the original experimental method.
And we identified six emotions from
different cultures that have never been
identified as universal,
that can't be translated into
English with a single word,
which is important because all of the
presumed universal emotions happen to be
English categories and,
um, they also don't exist.
And the language that is spoken
by the Hadza, uh, which is, um,
heads on a,
and then when we did is we invented
expressions for these emotions.
We just made them up.
Uh,
and in this case we were
using vocalizations,
although we have a version with faces,
but we were using vocalizations
because it's a complicated story,
but we were basically
replicating, uh, we're,
we were replicating another experiment,
um, and kind of criticizing it.
Um, so we use vocalizations.
So for example,
the category Giggle is,
uh,
the overwhelming urge to
squeeze or a pinch, something
that's very cute. You know,
when you see him cute
and you just want to,
you just want to squeeze the cheeks
of a baby. Right? Um, that's the,
that's the emotion.
Um,
and so we made up a
vocalization to go with that,
which sounds something like this.
Okay.
We made that sound and then we
asked our test subjects again from,
uh,
the Hadza test subjects to match each
sound with a little story that we told
about emotion because in remote samples,
um,
that are, um, you know, small scale, um,
societies that are very remote
from western cultures. Um,
typically the way these experiments are
done is you don't give them a list of
words.
You tell them a little story about the
emotion that contains the emotion word.
Uh, and then you give them two phases
or two vocalizations and you ask them to
basically pick the expression that
matches. So that's what we did.
Um, and then the average
accuracy actually, um,
was pretty high. And if you
look at the individual emotions,
five of the six of them look
universal. Um, and in fact,
these accuracy rates are pretty similar
to what you see in many studies of Ang
for fit, for anger,
sadness, fear, and so on.
So this is where the blue bars come from.
Scientists have been using really since
the 1960s and experimental method that
doesn't discover evidence for
universal expressions of emotion,
but it manufacturers that evidence this
method of providing test subjects with
linguistic cues is responsible for the
scientific belief that a scowl expresses
anger and only anger that
a smile expresses happiness
and only happiness and so
on.
And so if you're a company who wants to
build AI to perceive emotions in humans
by measuring their facial movements,
then um,
it's probably important to realize
that these famous configurations don't
actually consistently, um,
display disgust, anger,
and fear and so on.
And that it's a mistake to infer that
someone who has scowling is angry.
And in fact,
it's an,
it's a mistake to call a scowl and
anger expression because only sometimes,
um, it doesn't out isn't a scowl
indicative of anger. Instead,
what we see when we look at the
data is that variation is the norm.
And to show here,
I'll just show you what I mean.
So if you were looking at
this person's face, um,
how, how, how does she look to you? What,
what emotion does she seem to be
expressing? Sadness. She's sneezing,
not even an emotion at all,
smelling something good.
So usually this isn't yet.
Usually people see her as tired or,
um,
or as I'm grieving or as about to cry.
I'm sad. Um, actually this is, uh,
my daughter Sophia experiencing only
what I can only describe to you is a
profound and deep sense of pleasure,
um,
at the chocolate museum
in Cologne, Germany. Um,
okay.
And this little sweetheart
is also experiencing,
uh,
a profound sense of pleasure.
And the lesson here is that people move
their phases in many different ways
during the same emotion.
Now,
if we were to only look at this
little guy's eyebrows up to his,
you know, eyes and nose, um, this,
these facial actions actually are,
um,
very reminiscent of the
presumed expression for anger.
So for example,
um,
this face is often seen as angry.
Does anybody actually know who this is?
Jim Webb,
this is actually Jim Webb when he
won the senatorial race in Virginia,
which returned the Senate
to democratic control, um,
this victory return the Senate
to democratic control. Sorry,
I was just having a moment there.
Uh, and so without context,
we see his face as communicating
anger because actually, um,
this face symbolizes anger in our culture.
So people don't just move their faces in
different ways during the same emotion.
They also moved, yeah, their faces, um,
in the same way during different emotions.
So when in real life,
a face doesn't speak for itself,
when it comes to emotion,
right?
People usually see this guy a the fittest
face as smug or pride or confidence.
Um,
actually it's at the supposedly
universal expression for discussed.
And what's really interesting is that
when you stick a presume, you know,
the presumed expression for discussed
on a body or in any kind of context that
I'm suggests a different
emotion perceivers actually
track the face differently.
They're scanning of the face has a
completely different pattern suggesting
they're making different meaning of that
face on the road by virtue of the, um,
the context it's in. And I'll just
tell you as an aside in every,
well maybe that's an
exaggeration in most studies, um,
where you pit a face against a context,
the face always loses faces are inherently
ambiguous without contacts to make
them meaningful.
So what's up with these expressions?
Where did they come from?
Well,
it turns out that they were not discovered
by actually observing people as they
moved their faces, expressing
emotions in real life. In fact,
these are stipulated expressions.
So a handful of scientists just
anointed these as the expressions,
emotion as universal truths, and then
people built a whole science around.
So basically their stereotypes.
And um,
what we have is a science of
stereotypes or you know, emojis,
which by themselves I should tell you also
are highly ambiguous. It turns out, um,
without context.
Uh,
so obviously we don't want to
build a science, uh, of, uh,
artificial intelligence on stereotypes.
We want to build them on emotional
episodes as they occur in, in real life.
And in real life, an emotion
is not an entity, right?
It's a category that's filled
with variety. When you're angry,
your face does many things and your body
does many things and it turns out your
brain also does different things depending
on the context that you're in. Now,
for those of you who build classification
systems, you know about categories,
right? So for example, if
you were building a category,
uh, if you're building a,
a recognition system for cats,
a cat recognition system,
you would develop a classifier that could
learn the features that cats have in
common that distinguished them from other
animals like dogs and birds and fish
and so on.
And this cat Aghori get it.
My daughter made me say that. Okay.
This category, thank you for laughing.
Now I can tell her that you
thought it was funny. Um,
is a collection of instances that
has similar features, but you know,
there's actually plenty of variation in
these instances of this category too,
right? Some cats are
big, some cats are small.
Oh. Some cats have, um, you know,
cats have different eye colors.
Some cats have long first,
some have short for some have no fur.
MMM.
But the human brain tends to ignore this
variation in favor of what cats have in
common. And the interesting
thing is that, um,
humans also have the capacity to
make other kinds of categories,
categories where,
um,
there are no physical similarities where
the category is not based on physical
similarities of the instances. Um, and
this is something we do all the time.
For example, here's a category.
This is a category that every,
I'm sure everyone in this room knows.
Yeah.
You want to take a guess what it is,
human made objects.
I suppose if you treat the elephant
like a picture of an elephant,
then that would, that
would be true. Yeah. Okay.
Well these are all objects that you
can't bring through airport security.
Actually, the last time I did this one
clever person actually said they're all,
um, instances of things that you can
squirt water of. And I thought, well,
actually yeah,
if you think of the gun as a water
pistol then that that could work. Right.
Um,
this is a category that's
not made of instances that
chair physical features. Um,
instead they share a common function.
In this case,
squirting water through them or not
being able to take some through airport
security. Um, uh,
this category though exist inside our
heads and in the head of every adult who
has ever flown on an airplane. Um,
it's a category of social reality.
So for objects to belong
to this category, um, they,
they belong not because they all
share the same physical features,
but because we impose a similar function
on them by collective agreement,
we've all agreed that it
is not okay to take water,
uh,
through the water bottle
through security or a gun or a,
we're an elephant.
And in fact,
it turns out that most of the categories
that we deal with in civilization are
categories of social reality,
who's instances don't necessarily
share physical features,
but we've imposed the same function on
those features by collective agreement.
Can you, can you think of
any that might come to mind?
Things that we treat as similar,
but um, but are actually,
their physical features
actually vary quite a bit.
Money. Exactly. Money is the
money is a great example.
So throughout the course of human
history and actually even right now, um,
there's nothing about what humans have
used as currency that defines those
instances as currency.
It's just a group of people decide that
something can be traded for material
goods and so they can, um, and
you know, little pieces of paper,
pieces of plastic shells,
salt,
big rocks in the ocean, which
are immovable, um, mortgages.
And when we remove our
collective agreement,
those things lose their value,
right?
So one way of thinking about the
mortgage bubble is that, uh, mortgages,
the value of mortgages is based
on collective agreement and, uh,
some people removed their agreement.
Anything else?
Yeah,
that's true. You have to
work really hard to, uh,
accept the collective agreement, uh, of
driving on the wrong side of the road.
Oh, come on. Beauty. How about
citizenship of a country?
How about a country?
Right? If you go for example, into, um,
if you look at a map from a
1940s or before the 1940s,
the map of the world looks very different.
The map of the earth is
pretty much the same.
The physical features of the earth are
more or less the same. Um, but, uh,
but the countries are, that are
drawn, are, are different. Um,
so we could go on and on like this.
We can talk about, um, social roles,
like being married.
Marriage actually turns out is also
a category of social reality. Um,
the presidency of any
country is, uh, you know,
people don't have power because
they're endowed by nature, with power.
They have power because we all agree
that certain positions give you power.
And if we revoked our agreement,
then they wouldn't have power anymore.
Um, that's called the revolution. So, um,
the emotion categories are
our categories like this,
anger and sadness and fear
and so on. Um, our, um,
categories that exist because,
uh, by of collective agreement,
just in the same way that
we had to impose, um,
a function on the elephant that,
uh, that wasn't there before.
Um, in order for it to be
belong to this category, um, uh,
we also, um, impose meaning
on a downturn, mouth,
a scowl.
We impose meaning on that scowl as anger,
right?
So a scowl isn't inherently a
meaningful as anger. In this culture.
We've learned,
um,
to impose that meaning based on our
shared knowledge of anger and in um,
the Trobriand islands, they would
impose a different meaning. Um,
they post impose the
meeting of um, sorry, I've,
they impose a meeting on a different face
for anger, for the stereotype of anger.
It's a wide eyed, um, face,
a wide eyed gasping face.
And this is also what allows us to see
other expressive movements as anger,
right?
So what we're doing is imposing meaning
on a smile or on a stone face stare or
on a cry as anger in a particular
situation. It transforms,
mirror physical movements into
something much more meaningful,
which allows us to predict
what's going to happen next.
So if you want a machine to
perceive emotions in a human,
then it has to learn to
construct categories on the fly.
Perceiving emotions is
not a clustering problem.
It's a category construction problem and
it's a category construction problem.
Whether you're measuring facial movements
or bodily movements or the acoustics
of someone's voice,
or whether you're measuring the changes
in their autonomic nervous system or
even in the neural activity of the
brain or even all of those, right?
All of these things are physical changes
that aren't inherently meaningful as
um, emotions. Someone or something
has to impose meaning on them,
um, to make them meaningful, right?
So an increase in heart
rate is not inherently fear,
but it can become fear when it is,
um,
it's pressed into service to serve a
particular function in a particular
situation.
So emotions are not built
into your brain from birth.
They are just built as as you need them.
And this is really hard to understand
intuitively since you know,
your brain categorizes very automatically
and very effortlessly without your
awareness.
And so we need special examples to kind
of reveal to us what our brains are
doing,
um,
kind of categorizing very continuously,
and effortlessly. And so, um,
what I'd like you to do right now is
we're going to go through one of these
examples so I can, um, I
can explain it to you. So
here's a bunch of black and white blobs.
Um,
tell me what you see. Sorry, person,
person kicking a soccer ball.
Yeah,
an octopus.
One I'd octopus.
Okay. So, um,
right now what's happening in each of
your brains is that billions of your
neurons are working together to try
to make sense of this so that you see
something other than
black and white blobs.
And what your brain is actually doing
is it's searching through a lifetime of
past experience, issuing thousands
of guesses at the same time,
weighing the probabilities, trying to
answer the question, what is this like?
Not what is this,
but what is this like,
how similar is this to um,
past experiences?
And this is all happening
in the blink of an eye.
Okay?
Now, if you are seeing
merely black and white blobs,
then your brain hasn't found a good match
and you're in a state that scientists
call experiential blindness.
So now I'm going to cure you
of your experiential blindness.
This is always my
favorite part of any talk.
Should I do that again?
Yeah.
Now many of you see a B and the reason
why is that now as your brain is
searching through past experiences,
there's new knowledge there from the
coat color photograph that you just saw.
And the really cool thing is that
what you just saw a moment two ago,
um,
that knowledge is actually changing how
you experience these blobs right now.
So your brain is now categorizing this
visual input as a member of the category
B.
And as a result,
your brain is filling in lines
where there are no lines.
It's actually changing the firing of its
own neurons so that you see a B where
there is actually no be present.
This kind of category induced
hallucination is pretty
much business as usual for
your brain.
This is just how your brain works and
your brain also constructs emotions in
exactly this way.
And here's why.
Here's why it happens.
Because your brain is actually in tuned
in a dark silent box called your skull.
And it has to learn what is going
on around in the world by scraps of
information that it gets through
the sensory channels of the body.
Now the brain is trying to figure out
the causes of these sensations so that it
understands what they mean and it knows
what to do about them to keep you alive
and well.
And the problem is that the sensory
information from the world is noisy,
ambiguous. It's often incomplete.
Like we saw with the blobby B example.
And any given sensory input like a
flash of light can have many different
causes.
So your brain is,
has this dilemma and it doesn't just
have this dilemma based on sensory inputs
from the world. It also has
this dilemma to solve, um, uh,
regarding the sensory inputs
from your body. Um, so,
uh, there are sensations
that come from your body,
like your lungs expanding and
contracting and your heart beating. And,
um,
there are sensations from moving your
muscles and from metabolizing glucose and
so on and so forth. And, um, the, um,
the same,
uh,
kind of problem that we faced with having
to make sense of information from the
world. We also face from having
to make sense of our own bodies,
which are largely a mystery to
the brain or more or less. Um,
so an ache in your gut for example,
um,
could be experienced as hunger if
you were sitting at a dinner table.
But if you were in a doctor's office
waiting for test results, you, that gut,
that ache in your gut would
be experienced as anxiety.
And if you were a judge in a courtroom,
that ache would be experienced as
a gut feeling that the defendant,
um,
can't be trusted.
So your brain is basically constantly
trying to solve a reverse inference
problem because it has to determine
the causes of sensations when all it
actually has access to or the effects.
And so how does it do this?
How does the brain resolve this,
this reverse inference problem?
And the answer is by remembering past
experiences that are similar in some way.
So it's remembering past experiences
where physical changes in the world and in
the body are functionally similar
to the present conditions.
Okay.
Similar,
it's creating
basically categories.
So your brain is using past experience
to create ad hoc categories,
to make sense of sensory inputs so that
it knows what they are and what to do
about them.
And these categories represent the causal
relationships between the events in
the world and in the body
and the consequences,
which is what the brain actually detects.
And this is actually how
your brain is wired to work.
It's wired to work this way.
It's metabolically efficient
to work this way. Um,
and this is how your brain constructs
all of your experiences and guides all of
your actions.
Your brain begins with the initial
conditions in the body and in the world.
And then it predicts forward in time
predicting what's about to happen next by
creating categories that are candidates
to make sense of incoming sensory inputs
to make them meaningful so that
your brain knows what to do next.
And the information from the world and
from the body either confirms those
categories or it, um, it, uh,
prompts the brain to um,
to,
to learn something and
try again at updates. Um,
and then the brain makes another
attempt at categorization.
So emotions are not,
you know,
reactions to the world. They are
actually your constructions of the world.
It's not like something happens in the
world and then you react to it with an
emotion.
In fact,
what's happening is that your brain is
constructing an experience and an an
episode or an event, um, where it's,
what it's trying to do is make sense of
or categorize what is going on inside
your own body, like an ache in relation
to what's happening in the world.
Like being in a doctor's office.
So emotions are basically,
um,
brain guesses that are forged by
billions of neurons working together.
And so the emotions that seem to
happen to you are actually made by you.
And categorization is also how your
brain allows you to see emotions in other
people.
So your brain remembers past experiences
from similar situations to make meaning
of the present. You know, to make
meaning of the rays of an eyebrow or,
um,
the movement of the mouth and so on.
So to perceive emotion in somebody else,
what your brain is actually doing is
it's categorizing that person's facial
movements and their body movements and
the acoustics of their voice and the
surrounding context and actually stuff
that's happening inside their own bodies,
all conditioned on past experience.
So even though when we're
talking to each other,
we're mainly looking at each other's faces
and we're aware of each the movements
of each other's faces and we might
be maybe aware of the tone of voice.
We're now,
our attention is not given to the rest
of the sensory array that the brain has
available, including what's going
on inside your own body. You know,
your body inside your own body is a
context that you carry around with you.
Everywhere you go,
that is involved in every single
action and experience that your brain,
um, creates. Largely,
you are lord and you are
largely unaware of it actually.
And this is how,
um,
a scowl can become anger
or confusion were, uh,
indigestion or even amusement.
So that emotions that you seem to detect
and other people are partly made inside
your own head.
So when one human perceives
emotion and another person,
she is not detecting emotion,
her brain is guessing by creating
categories for emotion in the moment.
And this is how a single physical
feature can take on different emotional
meanings in different contexts.
So for a machine to perceive emotion,
it has to be trained on
more than stereotypes.
It actually has to capture
the full high dimensional,
the high dimensional
detail of the context, um,
not just measuring a face or a face and
a body which is inherently ambiguous
without the context.
So perceiving emotion means learning
to construct categories, um,
using the features from biology, um,
like faces and bodies and brains.
But in a particular context.
And I,
the thing I want to point out here is
that I'm using the context of the word
context pretty liberally here because
context also often includes the,
the actions of other people,
right?
So we are social animals and other
humans make up important parts of our
context, which suggests that when you
want to measure a, when you want to,
I'm sorry,
detect emotion in a person you want to
build AI and you measuring the context,
you might consider also measuring the
physical changes in the people who are
around that person because
that can give you a clue, um,
about uh, about what the physical
changes in the target person really need.
So measuring the features of other people,
um,
that is there physical changes and actions
that are contingent on the biological
changes in the person of interest is uh,
an extension of the con,
the idea of, of um, context
which is really important.
And the last few minutes,
what I'm going to do is switch gears here
and I'm from perceiving emotion to ask
whether it's possible to build machines
who can actually experience emotion
the way that humans do.
And this is a question I think that
interest AI people who work in AI often
because they are interested in,
in questions about empathy.
And so if emotions are made by
categorizing sensations from the body,
um,
and from the surrounding context,
using past experience than machines would
need all three of these ingredients or
something like them. And so we're
gonna just take this really quickly,
one at a time.
So the first this past experience,
can machines actually recall
past experience? Well,
machines are really great at storage
and retrieval. Unfortunately,
brains don't work like a file system.
Memories aren't retrieved like files.
They are.
Memories are dynamically
constructed in the moment.
And brains have this amazing capacity to
kind of combine bits and pieces of the
past in novel ways. Their brains
are generative. They are, um,
information, uh, gaining structures.
They can create new content,
not just merely reinstate old content,
which is necessary for
constructing categories on the fly.
To my knowledge, and maybe you
know, which might be out of day,
but to my knowledge,
there are no computing systems that are
powered by dynamic categorization that
can create abstract categories by grouping
things together that are physically
dissimilar. But because they, um,
they are all in that particular
situation serving a similar function.
So an important challenge for computers,
um,
to experience emotion is to,
to be able to develop a computing
systems that have that capability.
The second ingredient is context.
So computers are getting better and
better at sensing the world. Um,
though there are advances
in computer vision and um,
in speech recognition
and so on, um, but uh,
system doesn't just have to
detect information in the world.
It also has to decide which information
is relevant and which information is
not. Right. This is the signal
versus noise problem. Um,
and uh,
this is what scientists call value.
So value is not something
that's detectable in the world.
Value is not a property of, um, uh,
sights and sounds and so on or the
information that creates sights and sounds
and so on from the world.
Um,
value is a function of that information
in relation to the state of the organism
or the system that's doing the sensing.
So if there's a blurry
shape in the distance,
does it have value for you
as food or can you ignore it?
Well,
partly that depends on what the shape is,
but it also depends on when you last ate.
And even more importantly,
uh,
the value also depends on whether
or not that shape wants to eat you.
And so to solve this problem,
it turns out that, you know, um,
the brain didn't start off Britain.
If you look at brain evolution,
it didn't start off with systems that
allow creatures to compute value.
Those evolved in concert with sensory
systems in concert with the ability to see
and hear and so on. Um,
for exactly this reason.
Um,
and so the evolution basically gave us
brain circuitry that allows us to compute
value, which also gives us our mood
or what scientists call an effect,
which are simple feelings of feeling
pleasant, feeling unpleasant,
feeling worked up, feeling calm,
um, affect or mood is not emotion.
It's just a quick summary of the state
of what's going on inside your own body.
Like a barometer and aspect is a signal
that something is relevant to your body
or not. Whether that thing
has value to you or not.
And so for a machine
to experience emotion,
it also needs something that allows it
to estimate the value of things in the
world in relation to a body,
which brings us to the third ingredient.
Um,
brains evolved for the purposes of
controlling and balancing the systems of a
body.
Brains didn't evolve so that we could
see really well or here really well or
feel anything. They evolved
to control the body, um, to,
to keep, uh, the systems
of the body in balance.
And the bigger the body gets with the
more systems, the bigger the brain gets.
Um,
so a disembodied brain has
no bodily systems to balance.
It has no bodily sensations
to make sense of.
It has no effect to a signal value.
So a disembodied brain would
not experience emotion,
which means that for a machine to
experience emotion like a human does,
it needs a body or something like a body,
a collection of systems that it has to
keep in balance with sensations that it
has to explain. And to me, I think
this is the most surprising insight,
um,
about AI and emotion.
I'm not saying that a machine has to
have an actual flesh and blood body to
experience emotions, but I am suggesting
that it needs something like a body.
And,
um,
I have a deep belief that there are
clever engineers who can come up with
something that is enough like a body,
um,
to provide this necessary ingredient
for emotion. Now these ideas, uh,
and others, uh, the science
behind them, um, and,
and related ideas can be found in my book.
How emotions are made,
the secret life of the brain.
Um,
and there's also additional
information on my website. And, uh,
even though this is not strictly speaking,
I'm not throwing tons of data at you.
I do. I'm always at the end of
talks like to thank my lab. Um,
really are, they're the ones who
actually do all the really hard work. Um,
uh, you know, scientists like me just get
to stand up here and talk about it. Um,
so, um, uh,
I just want to thank them as well and
thank you for your attention and I'll take
it
questions.
I am wondering how someone who has say
blind from birth will perceive emotion
because they don't, um, they
cannot depend on visual cues,
whether it's facial
expression or body language.
So I'm guessing they
usually go off of, um, um,
vocal tones or lack there off.
Um,
have you looked into their accuracy of
predicting emotions and is that better or
worse than people who rely on visual cues?
So,
um,
people who are born congenitally blind
have no difficulty experiencing emotion
and they have no difficulty perceiving
emotion through the sensory channels that
they have access to because their brains
work largely in the same way that a
sighted person's brain works at birth.
The brain is collecting patterns,
statistical patterns,
um, and so, uh, it's just vision
isn't part of that pattern.
And what's really interesting
actually is that, um,
so for someone who is, is
congenitally blind, um, they, um,
they're learning patterns
that include, you know, uh,
changes in sound pressure that
become hearing changes, um, in,
um, the pressure on the skin, which
becomes touch. Um, they have taste,
they have sensations from the
body which become an effect.
So they can do multimodal
learning just like the rest of us.
And they can learn to
experience and express emotion
and perceive it through the
channels they have access
to. What's really interesting
is that when adults have,
um, let's say who are congenitally
blind because they have cataracts, um,
have those cataracts removed for
the first time, they can see,
yeah.
Or they should be able to see.
But actually it takes them
a while to learn to see.
And when they finally learned to see they,
their experience,
if you talk to these people,
what they say is that they're,
they feel like they're always guessing
what faces mean and what body postures
mean. They find faces
in particular hard. Um,
for example, even as I'm one,
there's one person, um, Michael May,
who's been studied really extensively
over a number of years and even a couple
of years, years after his cataracts were
replaced, um, is corneal, uh, sorry,
he had corneal abrasions that a,
so as cornea were replaced, um,
he was still guessing,
consciously guessing at whether a face
was male or female before someone spoke.
He just couldn't,
it was really hard for him to do.
And he experienced his vision as
separate from everything else,
like us, like a second language that
he was learning to, to speak, um,
which had no effect to
it. Right. So, um, so,
but the answer to your question
is, um, so you critique it,
ask a bunch of questions, like, so do
blind people who are congenitally blind,
do they actually make facial expressions,
you know,
the way that a sighted person
does and the answer is, um, they,
uh,
their facial movement,
they don't make the stereotypic
expressions when they're angry or sad or
whatever,
but they do learn to make sur deliberate
movements in a particular way.
Um, for example, um, when they are, there
are these studies showing that when,
um, congenitally blind athletes
win an award and they, uh,
they know they're being filmed,
um,
they will make a body movements
that indicate being really thrilled.
Um, uh, what they don't, but they're doing
it because they've learned it in the,
in the same way that if you
test a congenitally blind
person on the meaning of
color words,
they're mapping of color words largely
as the same as a sighted person because
they've stuttered.
They've learned from the statistical
regularities in language which words are
more similar to each other and which
ones aren't. So their abilities,
that emotion perception and emotion
expression largely look the same as a
sighted person's in what without the,
without the visual component was really
interesting is that people who are
congenitally deaf, who don't, who,
who tend to learn mental state language,
they develop concepts for mental states
later also are delayed in their ability
to perceive emotion in
other people. So, um,
that literature suggests
a coupling between, um,
emotion words and the ability to learn
to form emotion categories in childhood.
So, so you said that an essential
component in recognizing an emotion is the
context. I would never say
recognizing, but yeah, yeah. Um,
um,
if we didn't have the context and we could
monitor whatever's happening inside a
person's body and the brain really well,
uh,
would we be able to recognize emotions
and what specifically would it take?
What would we want to monitor?
Yeah, so it's interesting
that you, I mean,
when I was originally thinking
about giving this talk,
I thought I might start with, um,
machine learning, uh, attempts to,
um,
identify emotion with neural activity,
patterns of neural activity. And it
turns out that you can, in a given study,
uh, if you, um, if you
show people films, say,
uh, and you try to evoke
emotions by showing them films,
you can actually build a pattern
classifier that can distinguish, um,
uh, anger from sadness, from fear, um,
meaning you can distinguish when
people are watching films for that.
Will that presumably evoke anger
versus sadness versus fear?
The problem with those studies is that,
uh,
that classify or can't be used in another
study. Like it doesn't generalize,
right? So you're what you're
building is your building, um, uh,
a set of classifiers at work
in a specific context. Um,
but when you generalize,
try to generalize to another
sample of subjects maybe.
Um,
so let me say it this way.
If you have the same subjects
in the same study, watch movies,
and so you've voke anger by watching a
movie and you've voke anger by having
them, let's say, remember a prior
anger episode, um, you get, um,
you can classify the emotions
and distinguished from
one another and you can,
you get a little bit of carry over from
one modality of evoking to another.
But if you go to a
completely separate study,
the patterns look completely different.
And this is true across hundreds of
studies. So reasonable. We developed a,
we have a, I published a
pattern classification paper
where we use 400 studies,
um,
uh,
and we developed these classifiers based
on this metta analytic database that,
that those classifiers are not
successful at classifying any new set of
instances. I mean, they show
really good. Um, you know, I mean,
we used a leave one out method.
We used, uh, um, you know,
multivariate Basie and
a me, you know, there,
there are no problems with the
statistics. The issue is that, um,
when scientists do this, they believe
that what they're discovering, um,
in these patterns is actually a
literal brain state for the motion,
the literal brain state for anger.
And then they think it should generalize
to sell to every brains to every
instance of anger.
And they don't generalize usually
outside of their own studies. Um,
this is also true for
physiology. Um, where it,
so we just published a Meta analysis where
we examined the physiological changes
in people's bodies, like their
heart rate changes or breathing, um,
their skin conductance and so on. And, um,
you see that these physical measures
can distinguish one emotion,
sometimes one emotion category
from another in a study,
but they don't generalize across studies.
And in fact,
the patterns themselves really
changed from study to study. Um,
and so there's, uh, when you look
at it in a Meta analytic sense,
it looks like all in all for all emotions,
heart rates would go up or go down or
stay the same depending on what the
situation is.
So there's so far no one has
done a really high dimensional.
Nobody's made a really high
dimensional attempt at this.
Meaning they haven't tried to measure the
brain and measure the body and measure
the face and measure
aspects of the context. Um,
that's actually what I
think needs to be done.
So I think this is a solvable problem.
I just think we have not been going
about it in the right way. Um,
and I think that this is a
real opportunity, uh, for, um,
okay
for any company that is
serious about doing this.
I love the way you mentioned in the
book that, and then the talk as well,
how we perceive emotions based on context.
So we look at the context
and then we for emotion.
And one of the examples that
you have in the book and,
and you have here as well was a Serena
Williams winning a grand slam and you
have her here,
you have the versions.
Why I switched it out because
people were starting to say, oh,
that's Serena Williams. I'm like,
okay, well that's right. Yeah.
So, but there's something that is
troubling to me at least in that,
in that example.
Um,
well I think that's, that's certainly
possible. And what I would say,
what I would say to that
though is, um, that um,
there are studies particularly
by a Hillel Fvs are,
who's actually done work
with you? No, he didn't.
I published the picture of
Serena Williams and I'm 2007.
I published that example and um,
hello,
came out with a great set of experiments
in 2008 and then again in 2012 and he
proceeded to continue where he
knows he has the reports of people,
people's subjective experience
and he has their facial movements.
Um, and in fact there are
Meta analyses which, uh,
have the subjective reports of people
and their facial movements and in
sometimes also the reports of people
interacting with the people whose faces,
but, and there is um, no evidence
that, um, that the, that,
that the
variability is due to a series of
quick emotions being evoked over time.
So what, you know, but I want to
back up one step and say this when,
when you asked the question,
um,
well maybe Serena Williams
is really experiencing,
maybe she really is in a state of anger
in that moment or in that case it's
actually looks like fear
more or terror more.
Um,
uh,
when you say really that implies that
there's some objective criteria and that
you could use to measure the state
that Serena Williams has really in.
And there is no objective criteria for
any emotion that's ever been studied ever.
Okay.
So what scientists use is agreement.
They use collective agreement essentially.
So you can ask, does the face,
does it face match her report?
Does the face match somebody else's report
due to people agree on what they see.
So you're using all kinds of
basically a perceiver based agreement,
which is basically consensus,
um,
because no one has found the,
there is no ground truth when it comes
to emotion that anyone has ever found
that replicates from study
to study. Um, and so,
so there's a part of me that wants to say,
I can't even answer your question because
I think it's not even a scientific
question that's answerable, but, but
we can answer it in other ways by see,
by looking at various forms of consensus.
And while I can't say anything about
Serena Williams and what she experienced,
I can say that in other studies it's
very clear that people are scowling.
Absolutely. When they are
not angry. My husband,
this is my husband Dan Barrett
who works for Google. Sorry honey,
I'm going to out you. Um, you know, key
Scott, he gives a full on facial scowl,
uh,
when he's concentrating really hard.
And it was only after I learned that,
that I,
and I was telling my students actually
like, can you believe? And they're like,
can we believe it?
We experience it every time we give a
presentation in front of you. Right?
So I'm sitting there are,
you know,
paying a lot of attention to every
single thing they say and they think,
oh my God, she hates it.
And the whole, uh, you know,
emotional climate and my lab changed
the moment that I realized that. So,
so that, you know, that's an anecdote,
but it's an anecdote that reflects
what is in the literature,
which is that people are making a variety
of fish. I'm not saying it's random,
I'm saying there's a pattern.
There are patterns there that
we haven't really yet detected.
And I think it's in part because we are
measuring individual signals or we think
we're doing really well if we measure
the face and the body or we measure the
face and acoustics or measure the face
and something about, you know, uh,
maybe heart rate that we pick,
we pick up two channels instead of
doing something really high dimensional.
I'm not saying there's no meaning there.
If there was, if that were true, we,
you know,
you and I couldn't have a conversation
right now I'm saying that it's probably
something high dimensional and it might
be quite idiographic meaning there could
be different, different brains
may be have the capacity to do um,
a different number of categories to
make different number of categories.
And um, that's also something
I discuss in my book actually.
So when you listed all the,
uh,
the sort of pre qualifications for maybe
emotion forming, um, I was thinking, um,
you know, a lot of vegetarians say,
oh, you know, all animals have feeling,
have this ability to,
to emote and to feel emotion.
And a lot of mediators are
like, no, no, no, no, no, no,
that's impossible. They don't.
Um, do you have any opinion? Yeah,
here's my opinion. I think that, um,
I think everybody has to stop
calling affect like many, many,
many problems disappear.
They just completely dissolve.
When we understand that every
waking moment of our lives,
there's stuff going on inside
our bodies and we can't,
we don't have access to the small,
every little small change in our
bodies that gives that sense sensory
information to the brain.
If we did,
we would never pay attention to anything
outside our own skins ever again.
So instead,
evolution has given us an effect.
So we sense what's going on inside
our own bodies by feeling pleasant or
unpleasant feeling worked
up or feeling kind of calm,
feeling comfortable or uncomfortable.
That's not emotion,
that's an affect or mood that's with us
always every waking moment of your life
you have some effect,
there are some aspect of features to
your experience and it's very likely also
true of of nonhuman
animals. Um, I, you know,
I can say this circuitry is,
is,
is very similar, similar enough that
I think you could go down all the way,
uh, to, um,
certainly all vertebrates and I
would even guess that there are some
invertebrates, um, actually maybe
all invertebrates, I don't know,
even insects potentially
could actually have an effect,
although I think that's drawing.
I mean I might draw the line at
like flies or something, but,
but recently there was a study that came
out that suggested maybe they do have
ethics. So in my feeling about
this is I guess two fold.
One is I think we have to stop conflating
an affect and emotion aspect is with
you always, even when you, you
experience yourself as being rational,
even when you experience yourself as
just thinking or just remembering,
it's just that one aspect is super strong.
Our brains explain it as emotion.
Once we make that distinction and
we understand that distinction,
that emotions and an effect maybe effect,
you could think of it
as a feature of emotion.
It's actually a feature of consciousness.
Then I think we can
say without hesitation,
we don't know for sure whether
nonhuman animals, uh, feel an effect.
Um, but they probably do and we should
probably treat them as if they do. Um,
that that solves a lot of problems.
It actually doesn't matter really. Um,
from a moral standpoint,
whether an animal feels emotion,
it matters whether they can feel pleasure
and pain. That's enough. Actually,
it's an interesting scientific
question whether or not they can,
they can see their brains
can create emotion.
That's a whole different conversation.
But I think the answer to your
question isn't really about emotion.
It's about an effect. And I think
there, it's really obvious that, um,
if you're going to the smart thing to do,
you just want to do things where you
do the least amount of damage if you're
wrong. Right. And so that means
including animals in our moral,
um, circle, right. They can feel,
if you just assume they
can feel pleasure and pain,
that solves a lot of problems.
Yep.
Thank you so much for your time. So
you mentioned at the end, I guess, um,
to answer the question,
if machines can experience emotion,
the three things and then body was
one of them. And then earlier on,
or you also mentioned,
I guess one purpose to have to create
emotions is like to know what to do next.
So my question is if a
being without a body,
like a machine really
need that body element.
If the purpose of that being is
different than just, you know,
knowing what to do next,
therefore can be tagged that body out of
the one of the three requirements based
on a different purpose of that beam.
That's a great question.
That is a great question. So
if the,
so can you give me an example?
It would be help me,
well,
I don't have an example by the way,
I'm thinking amendment when I went
to meet and I hear machines. Yeah.
And you're modeling all based on in
humans and we have your body and then you
had a purpose or if you have a rule. Yup.
Yup. We have a purpose to have emotions.
Like we are creating them maybe
at the beginning for survival.
Maybe it's different social elements
that, yeah, but if you take the body of,
you can still have a brain octane
oil intelligence. We thought nobody,
which is a different bean or elements,
Darfur,
I'm questioning that model
of three things needed. Yep.
You know, here's the thing
you need to have. Um,
so you'd need to have something that could
tell the machine what it needs to pay
attention to in the world and what it
can ignore. So value. Right. So, I mean,
let me back up and say it this way.
I mean,
I don't know how else to think about
it except in organic terms, right?
But for example,
if you were to look at brain evolution,
if I were to say it really
simply like super simplistically,
so I'm just glossing over
like a ton of detail.
Organisms first developed a motor,
a sort of a rudimentary motor system
with just a tube for like a gut.
That's it.
They used to just float around in
the sea and kind of like filter food.
And it wasn't until the Cambrian
explosion when there was a,
like a lot of oxygen and other things.
And so a lot of, um, uh, you know,
an explosion of diversity of life that
predation developed and predation was a
selection pressure for the
development of two things.
Sensory systems.
So these little like floating
tubes had no visual system.
They had no rudimentary visual system
where auditory system or they had not,
no sensory systems, they didn't really
need them. And they also had no internal,
uh, uh, nervous system to control any,
any systems inside because they didn't
have any systems really inside except the
motor system and a gut.
And that was it. Um,
so they had to develop sensory systems,
whether they're a Predator or prey, you,
most predators, also our PR, our pray,
right so that they could stay,
could sense they have to develop distance
census so they could detect what was I
going to, what was out there. Um,
but they also had to figure out
what was meaningful and what wasn't.
What was valuable because it's expensive
to run a system and learn the two most
expensive things that any other humans
or any Oregon ganache system can do is
move and learn. And so, um, it needs,
and so the development of the
systems of the body sort of serve,
serve the purpose of helping to
determine the value to the organism.
Now, it turned out that, you know,
along the way that those systems
also developed Sensei, you know,
develop the capacity to sensation
sensations to the brain,
which had to be made sense of if you
completely demolished that and you say,
okay, well you have a um,
um, a machine that um,
um,
it's purpose isn't to sense things in
the world and make sense of them then,
um,
so that it can predict what to do next.
Then maybe you don't need a body but
then you're not even talking about
something that is,
I don't even know.
I mean you'd have to give me an example
for me to kind of reason through it in
terms of the energetics and the,
I wonder if maybe body is throwing
me off because yeah, like a AI,
it's purpose can be also survive to
exist and can be an they just very
simplistically he needed it needs electric
city or its connection to the cloud
or something.
But that can be its body.
But what's its function?
What does it do?
Yeah, what do you mean? Like what? Like,
it doesn't just, you plug it in and it
doesn't just sit there, it does something.
What's its function?
What does it do?
Uh, do you mean dots? Full
intelligence? What does it do well,
so you're saying, um, okay, it gets
its energy from a plug. I, I get that.
But what is it actually attempting to
recognize or do or what's its function?
I mean we can use it for,
I don't know if some industrial experience
or maybe so southwest driver car AI
for example. And then
what I'm saying is, okay,
okay, so it's driving a car.
It's driving a car for you.
It has to sense things in the world.
Right. And then the question is Ken, Ken,
it experience emotion and
then your three model.
I agree the two of two.
And then I was questioning about
the body and then maybe the body is,
what is it reflecting body is,
is survival to create that value they
thing we're talking about the second one.
Yeah.
I would
say, here's what I would say.
I would say, okay, well let's,
let's take this as an example.
I don't know.
I'm just doing this off the top of my
head, but let's take as example, so,
so sure you can just plug it in and it
can get its energy from an electrical
outlet,
but still you want to have an
efficient machine that uses electricity
efficiently. Otherwise that would be
like more expensive than it needs to be.
And so,
um,
that means that you'd want it to do things
predictively because that's actually
more energy efficient.
That's why the human body doesn't
care or actually any at all.
Brains are structured to work efficiently,
not because of the, the, you know, the,
the energy source there is glucose
and other, other, um, organic sources.
So it's the same principle basically,
in fact, electrical machines. In fact,
the whole idea of predictive coding,
which is what I'm talking about,
comes from cybernetics.
Um,
and then human research researchers
who were studying humans were like, oh,
wait a minute. That actually could be
really useful for explaining things here.
So you'd still want it
to be super efficient.
Presumably if it's driving a car,
it has to determine what's,
what it has to pay attention to. And
what it doesn't, it can't be energy.
It can't be frivolous and it's
a and its energy use, right?
So it's gotta be predictive and it has
to basically not pay attention to some
things and it probably has a bunch of
systems that it has to keep in balance so
that it's working efficiently.
Um,
that's so far counts as there's nothing
in there that actually violates anything
that I've said. I think I was, I was
trying to be really careful to say,
when I say a body, I don't literally
mean a flesh and blood body.
I mean one of your brain's basic jobs
is to keep the systems of your body in
balance and that requirement,
which is called allostasis,
that requirement forces a lot of other
things to be true about how the system
works.
Um,
so if you want,
um,
if you want an AI to do
anything like a human,
it has to be put under the same
selection pressures as a human,
not literally with flesh
and blood. If, however,
you're talking about a function that a
human can't do or that isn't relevant to
humans then any, Nah, nothing
I've said is relevant to you,
probably I at all right because we're
only talking about about humans,
but could a car he could of could of
computer that drives a car feel emotion.
Maybe if
it
had sensory inputs that
it had to make sense of.
But the problem is that I don't know that
I would call that emotion because for
human we make a distinction between the
brain makes a distinction between the
sensations from the body and the
sensations from the world. If I were,
if there, if you didn't have
sensations from your body, you,
you wouldn't have an effect.
And so it just wouldn't be the same.
But I don't know.
I mean,
may I maybe I can't really answer but um,
maybe,
maybe
actually can I try to kind of offer
one idea that my combining both. Yeah.
So what if emotionally just
kind of characteristic for
how your body feels like
you don't have enough computing power to
process ever since you summarize it and
machine in that regard?
Would neither Sam curistics.
If it's not allowed from
then it would be a motion.
So like either heuristics will
tell like substance Bra, Ronan,
oh my view was an off.
That can be in a way seen as emotions and
for us it would be like Samsung is all
from me. I feel pain. You don't
really know her pain is, but yeah,
that's a signal food for
deeper investigation. Right.
And might be one of the causes is,
I mean I don't believe our brain is a
pinnacle of engineering at least and
causes, no, no. Like I
correct me if I'm wrong,
but let's say it's a frequency of our
neurons was like hundred hertz. A second.
So it was a band is you really like
limited and is only thing that gives us a
life is that you kind of like candid
billions and machine might not need that
because the frequency was I calling it.
Right. But I think it's,
maybe I'm wrong, but it means,
I think it comes down to a
philosophical question, like, okay, so,
so a machine that's
driving a car would have,
since we'd have sensory inputs that it
has to make sense of and it would have to
do it predictably and all of that,
but so it would have to have category,
would have to do ad hoc categorization
and it would have to, um,
or maybe not. But I think that would
probably be the efficient way to do it.
So it's making categories
and it's perceiving things,
but so when does that become an
emotion and when doesn't it, I mean,
you could also ask that of um,
uh, humans, right? I mean, we,
I mean, you know, nobody asked
me this question, but yeah.
Like what is the difference between an
emotion category in any other kind of
category that emit human [inaudible]
can develop, you know, any kind of,
any other kind of category that is of
this sort, which is ad hoc and, um,
of social reality. And the answer
is nothing. Nothing is different.
Um, so I, you know,
in some ways it's a not a question I
think that science can answer because in
this culture we've drawn a
boundary and we've said, well,
these things are emotions and
these things aren't there.
They're wrapped their thoughts and in
half the world people don't make that
distinction.
So is it possible to um,
to develop category, you know,
to do ad hoc categorization?
Do you do it predictively to make
sense of the world or sensations,
sensory input from the world
without a body? Sure, sure.
You could do it without a body,
but then it probably wouldn't be what we
would call human emotion or what feels
to us like human emotion, but, but
of course, you know, it, it would be,
it could be similar,
I guess to the experiences
that our brains can make. Um,
but I, I don't know. I have to
think about it more. Actually,
my iPad is speaking to me.
Yeah. Thanks Lisa for a great, a great
presentation. I had a followup question.
Do we believe that if the human brain
and consciousness, good process,
all of the intraceptive signals
everything from the world,
all the persons in real time,
so there's no bandwidth issue,
supposedly human brain could just process
everything. The first question is,
do you believe we would still have an
effect like this sort of simple state of
where we are supposedly
could just represent every
piece of information coming.
And the followup question
is that depending on their
answer to that is how, how,
how that relates to our notion
of emotional experience.
So in order though, for us, so
for us to have high dimensional,
in order for us to have, let me, let
me think about this for a second.
So if we could sense everything,
all of the neurons, everything,
every, so our wiring
changed, right? Because we,
the reason why we can't is that
we don't have the wiring to do it,
but would we have an effect that's sound?
Everything was at the same time, I
think. Yes. I think we still would.
And I'll tell you why we would,
because the way the brain is structured,
it's structured to do dimension
reduction and compression of information.
So if you were to look at the cortex and
you were to sort of take the cortex off
the subcortical parts of the brain and
just lifted off like a and stretch it out
like a Napkin and you were to
look at it in cross section,
what you would see is that you go from
primary sensory regions like primary
visual cortex or primary
and Tara Septic Cortex,
which is where the information
from the body goes to.
There are a lot of little pyramidal cells,
um,
with few connections,
which,
and the information cascades to the
front of the brain where there are fewer
cells, which are much bigger with
many, many, many connections.
But the brain is doing with all sensory
inputs is it's doing compression,
it's doing dimension reduction.
Um,
that's how multimodal learning hat,
that's how really all learn
learning happens essentially. Um,
so I think it happens in vision.
It happens with audition.
And so I think even if we could have,
even if we had higher
dimensional access to what's the,
the sensory changes in the body,
I still think given the way
that the cortex is structured,
we would still experience,
we would still have an effect,
which basically effect is just a low
dimensional representation of the stuff
going on inside your body.